so I'm going to uh bookend this
interview with some positivity because
that line it was like he took my voice
that day just when I was about to start
finding it just has crushed me every
single time I watch this movie so in an
effort to highlight some of the good out
there that we need more of can each of
you tell me about someone that you
encountered early on in your careers who
made you feel supported and respected
and helped you take a positive first
step forward when you were first
starting out
well on my first film
um
well I don't know I had never done a
film before and I didn't know anything
about
um
filming
um and uh I didn't know what a Mark was
I didn't know how to match my actions I
didn't know uh what a close-up was and
you know this was on glory and Denzel
Washington and Morgan Freeman really put
their arms around my shoulders and led
me through the process of how to work
with the camera how to understand how to
bring out my performance
um how to modulate it you know for for
the camera and uh I'm uh forever
grateful for that I mean our careers
have gone in a million different
directions and I haven't worked with
either one of them since 1989 but they
were part of uh the foundation of my
career in film and television and so I'm
very grateful to them today for what
they did in 1989. I had the similar
objects
shot the very first movie I ever did was
The Untouchables with you know De Palma
directing De Niro Kevin Costner but of
you know De Palma was remarkable to me
I'd never been on film uh he taught me
all about film
he was so uh
loving to me and uh
wonderful and I was broke and he
convinced Paramount that Mrs Ness had to
be all through the courtroom even though
there was one quick close-up of me that
was it and but I got paid for an extra
month and it saved me
he saved me
and uh so he was such a mentor you know
he's my first big film encounter and I
know Brian De Palma you know kind of a
bad boy and crazy guy in Hollywood but
he was incredible to me and I'm um
always thankful for how he really stood
up for Mrs Ness
I love it all right so to get into some
specifics here Patricia I was reading
that you chose not to meet the real
Rebecca before filming so you could more
organically invent the character but I
was wondering how did you come to the
conclusion that that was the best path
for you and ultimately the best thing
for the movie
well I came to that conclusion because
once I met Rebecca I realized oh I'm so
glad because you know she is formidable
she is
um this uh towering figure for me
um and one of the highlights of my
career in life to play uh this Valiant
fiercely intelligent woman I really did
have to call on my better angels and
um I I didn't want to mimic her or try
to become her play her I I wanted to
just bring the best to myself to this
woman for one month I just had to be the
best Patty could be
I was reading that in the production
notes there's a quote from you that says
I really did have to call in the best
parts of myself to capture her so is
there anything specific our viewers can
look out for that that's not only
Rebecca but that's you too well I mean
it's me occasionally it's Rebecca always
no just her her intuition her calm her
fierceness her unwilling unwillingness
to compromise she just but she's she's
steady she stayed the course and I'm a
much more emotional and frantic person
and she
and her Fierce intelligence and her gift
for Words her beautiful gift for words
and uh and to knowing you know when the
words are right and when they're not uh
uh it's a remarkable gift yeah anyone
who can do that I definitely deeply
admire them
um Andre I'll throw that same question
to you uh did you have the opportunity
to meet uh the real Dean and if so why
did you choose to do that versus waiting
until after filming uh I waited until
after uh filming um because
um I began to realize very on in the uh
the the examination of the script that
this was not the uh comprehensive total
Dean Dean has so many many more
complicated interesting aspects to his
uh character the the dean that this film
demands is the dean who's the leader The
Protector the mentor and the guide and
so every scene is about protecting his
reporters uh from um Harvey protecting
the investigation protecting their
integrity their Spirits you know
um how necessary that is so the one
aspect that I emphasize throughout the
entire film was
um the encouragement uh the wisdom the
the the love and protection that Dean is
offering to his reporters and the people
around him now that's not the whole Dean
so he might consider this to be a really
soft kind of performance but um but I
think that's what the script abandoned
you've very successfully accomplished
that every single time you appear in a
doorway I just like and put at ease for
everyone in this movie
um so obviously this is a very large
Ensemble and you just said it's you know
it's not the full Dean maybe we don't
get every single ounce of Rebecca so are
there any small details that you
determined were important to you that
maybe aren't at the center of a frame
maybe aren't conveyed via dialogue but
they were important to you and we could
at least feel them informing your
performances well I think it comes back
to that that calm and that quiet and
that you know she the the kind of
all-knowingness that you know if you can
just sometimes if you know in the middle
of a scene you know when there are many
other people you know if you cut to
Rebecca trust me she's far ahead of
everybody else in that room she's the
woman with the most experience sometimes
in that room she's the woman who really
has seen a lot and knows a lot
and just that's what I'm hoping is in my
eyes even for a brief moment in those
scenes
she knows what the hell's happening
can confirm
I'm not gonna mess with you Patty no
joke
for you Andre anything in particular
that isn't necessarily addressed
specifically in the movie but uh you
were kind of carrying with you
I have to say
that has eluded me I I wasn't carrying
um any
particular aspect of it I have to I I
have to say I failed on that uh on that
note um all right my apologies fail in
the question succeed big time in the
movie I'll take it all right I promised
my my positive uh bookend here to close
this out so obviously there's still a
whole bunch about this industry that
needs to change but a lot of good has
happened over the years so in an effort
to highlight a little of that what is
something that is now an industry Norm
that if you could go back and tell your
younger self like one day that's going
to be a given and it would make you
really happy what would you choose I I
would choose the fact that you know the
what we tolerated in the 80s 90s 2000s
is no longer tolerable that
silence is not golden you are complicit
that this business really we have we
have safety in numbers now there are now
more women in front of the camera behind
the camera in very big positions of
power and we have risen we will rise if
I had known many many years ago that I
would sometimes now be the powerful
person in a room
I'd be I it's so exciting to sometimes
be the person who has the biggest voice
in a room and it's remarkable
uh I'd have to say uh for me
um you know the respect in the workplace
um which it
I because I didn't have to put up with
the kind of sexual harassment that women
have for decades you know I I think the
biggest change for me over these 40
years and this is a part of uh respect
in the workplace uh empowerment in the
workplace uh um is uh respect in the
storytelling so
throughout my career
um this is a long tail but throughout
throughout my career
um stories about black men have been
um monstrously negative
um and um and it's been hard to find
roles that were uh personally empowering
and Humane and what I find today is 40
years later you know is that the stories
are commonplace in their understanding
of all our common Humanity whereas that
wasn't true in the 80s and 90s
um one of the reasons I didn't work as
frequently as I wanted to throughout all
of these four Decades of my career is
because the storytelling has been so
anti-human uh when it comes to stories
for black men and that's radically
changing today my son who's an actor has
um a different perspective a different
opportunities as a black man in his
business and to me that's a marvelous
achievement because
um
uh
uh it's a marvelous treatment period
it's important
um and so so I'm I'm glad to do my part
to to to push this story forward uh to
add my small talents to this large film
uh to make sure that people understand
this message about respect in the
workplace about confronting abusers and
about empowerment I've kept you both too
long but I will say goodbye thank you
and huge huge congratulations
congratulations on this film played
exceptionally well at AFI Fest really
really something else in that crowd